[Applaudissements]
dimanche 31 janvier c'est la finale de
la coupe d'afrique des nations d'un côté
l'équipe des pharaons égyptiens de
l'autre celle des black stars ghanéens
à la courneuve c'est jour de fête pour
ahmad un des cinquante mille égyptiens
de france pas question que cet ancien
joueur de foot professionnel
entrepreneur dans le bâtiment loupe
l'événement depuis qu'il est arrivé en
france il ya 22 ans il n'a pas manqué un
match de son équipe
aujourd'hui c'est en direct sur al
jazeera sport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la rencontre commence bientôt les hommes
les femmes la famille les amis tout le
monde joue les supporters bien plus
qu'un match c'est un enjeu national
chaque fois qu'on va entrer dans un
personnage
après l'egypte ce jour la coupe de
france
déjà c'est l'egypte va
ya
oui
on a entendu le losc observe au même
moment à sarcelles là où la communauté
ghanéenne est la plus représentée koffi
et ses amis s'organisent tant bien que
mal pour regarder le match sur le
satellite ils se sont donné rendez vous
dans un restaurant chez maman afrique a
pour l'instant pas de connexion le match
c'est dans dix minutes alors ça va
ça soit du tout avancement du tout donc
c'est plus qu'on va faire à mon avion va
pas pouvoir regarder le match soit
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît we have had et le gard
et s'intéresse celle qu'elle remplace
fait le plein de la victoire le bas de
la victoire c'est cette sauce comme
celle là
celle là et la sauce clair plus la cour
est pourquoi cette pleine face et ça
c'est le plat c'est le plat du ghana la
rue comme ça c'est le club du gamin
jeudi sa gamme ainsi gagné
[Applaudissements]
17 heures l'homme en noir siffle le coup
d'envoi c'est parti pour 90 minutes de
jeu et d'angoissé
mais pour les égyptiens l'important ce
n'est pas seulement de participer
à la corpiq six fois
[Musique]
son gain ce soir-là vollaro
aux salaires pour les égyptiens
après une première mi-temps plan-plan
côté gars n'a toujours pas de réseau pas
de stress non plus on s'organise comme
on peut c'est le système d oui on est en
jouant en blanc
un événement assez important tout gamin
pas tout et qu'on mettra dans tous les
satellites donc allé voir tout le monde
a
crié de 80 minutes de jeu toujours pas
de but la pression monte hélas
[Applaudissements]
ouais
quoi
côté ghana on a un métro de retard le
technicien le sauveur vient tout juste
d'arriver personne ne sait encore qu'un
but vient d'être marqué
quand la télé se rallument enfin c'est
pour découvrir au ralenti que les
égyptiens ont mis le cuir au fond des
filets
[Musique]
j'avais pas franchement
ce n'est pas gagné il reste trois
minutes à jouer ahmad stress dans le
couloir
4 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
cette fois c'est bon l'egypte est
championne d'afrique pour la septième
fois un record inégalé
aulas rodarte y menant
dont la rue hamad et sa bande vont y
aller aussi mais ce sera sur les
champs-elysées étape obligatoire de
toute victoire sportive qui se respecte
[Musique]
et pour ahmad emporté par la foule
plusieurs centaines de compatriotes la
nuit risque d'être longue
[Applaudissements]
de leur côté les ghanéens sont bons
joueurs
ils savent bien qu'ils pourront se
rattraper à la coupe du monde les
égyptiens éliminé de la compétition les
regarderons à la téloche
[Applaudissements]